[Music]
you now are playing ken
yeah well i have that energy
[Music]
can you explain the kenergy for me do
you know what i mean no you know a can
in your life and then you know that that
can has kennedy well it's the
cannassance per it's the catastrophe
yeah
i feel like my man has started a real
renaissance like a kenneth
did you love that she coined that term
for you i loved it i thought it was um i
loved him
i love that she's got love for ken that
means a lot to me
people are going nuts for the photos of
it i can't i can't wait that's nothing
that's nothing i can't wait for people
to see the film it's not what you expect
that's all i can say okay
otherwise mattel will come in and
box me up
for now you can see an equally buff ryan
targeted by chris evans in the gray man
hitting theaters friday and netflix july
22nd
what was the training like for this role
to get in shape for that to do those
scenes it's all the boring stuff that
you know like you lift heavy things you
don't eat a lot of other things and yes
i do you know some of it
but any you know incredible stunt team
incredible special effects team you see
a shot of your arm and it's it looks
huge right
did you bulk up more for this role than
any other part before yeah it was a very
physical challenge in in in every way
which role then maybe were you more
buffed for the gray man or barbie
because we see ken's abs yeah that ken
life is even harder than the gray man
life i think really yeah ken's got no
money he's got no job he's going through
some stuff
we haven't seen you on screen in a
couple years what made you want to come
back with this movie you know i've
always wanted to make an action film i
they're what made me fall in love with
movies you know i i just uh took me a
long time to find the right one you hurt
i mean my ego's a little bruised in the
movie ryan's a cia operative getting
help from fellow agent ana de armas
who's also all in on his other role as
ken the denim vest shirtless the abs the
ken underwear oh yeah you know what's
funny my brother's in the movie my
younger brother is in the movie those
photos have your approval they do
definitely
yeah they've been approved
anna is also speaking out about her past
with ex ben affleck telling elle being a
target of paparazzi was quote horrible
that's one of the reasons why i left la
it became a little bit too much she now
lives in new york with her new man
tinder exec paul bugadakis
[Music]